salut tous les lundis sur ma chaîne
youtube c'est le jour du blog à chaque
fois je vous emmène dans l'un des
endroits où je suis allé dans la semaine
un endroit que je trouve
particulièrement intéressant mais dans
les commentaires vous m'avez fait
remarquer que vous ai jamais fait voir
où est ce que j'habitais donc je vais
vous faire voir aujourd'hui dans les
commentaires de ce week-end vous êtes
nombreux à penser que j'habite à la
rochelle alors non j'habite pas à la
rochelle je suis né à la rochelle j'y ai
vécu la majeure partie de ma vie toute
ma famille est encore là bas certains de
mes amis sont encore là bas mais
maintenant j'habite à paris et plus
précisément j'habite ici c'est ici dans
cette cour que les gens regardent le mec
qui se filment par la fenêtre et qu'ils
comprennent pas ce que je fais en fait
alors ça évidemment c'est mon immense
terrasse pour manger l'été vous souvenez
d'été c'est un concept dont vous vous
souvenez encore ou pas c'est c'est quand
à partir du mois de juin il fait beau
pas quand il fait ce temps-là
dégueulasse on arrive dans la pièce
principale oui j'habite au rez de
chaussée j'habite au rez de chaussée
mais c'est pas très gênant puisque comme
le premier bâtiment sont très éloignées
j'ai quand même pas mal de luminosité et
en plus je peux observer les voisins
ainsi qu aux pattes
ici vous avez l'espace repas comme qui
dirait ou où nous pouvons manger un
autre espace repas plutôt dédié à
vanille ekwalla bien manger elle prend
les partitions et jouer un petit peu de
guitare ça c'est des graines de menhir
que j'ai ramené de carnac je vous
recommande
ça fait pousser des menhirs 1 et comme
on peut le lire pour les planter dans un
sol celtes et humide
la croissance par contre est très lente
les premiers siècles je pense pas que ce
soit une arnaque
je pense que c'était vraiment une bonne
affaire les lumières avec lesquels vous
pouvez me voir en temps normal alors à
côté de la lumière il ya tout ce que
j'appelle le home staging incitatif des
jolis objets faits maison
on appelle ça du tout ticket à 1
quasiment l'espace allons bien sûr voilà
où je peux je peux m'asseoir pour
regarder la télévision
cette vidéo est d'une importance
capitale quand même j'ai l'impression en
même temps c'est vous qui avez demandé
le lit de vanille si souvent squattés
par tam à l'eau et ça c'est le spot de
tamalous à la base
et ça c'est le grattoir de ta mal au
grattoir qu'il utilise très peu
puisqu'il est beaucoup plus intéressant
d'utiliser ce fauteuil 1 n'est ce pas ou
alors ce canapé
voilà merci beaucoup de mal aux d'avoir
un petit peu personnalisés toutes les
affaires de cette maison mais bon vous
allez me dire c'est qu'un siéger qu'un
canapé
oui oui c'est qu'un siéger qu'un canapé
ou ou même tous les autres sièges de
cette maison et je pense qu'un jour je
vais brûler ce chat dommage qu'ils aient
pas une vidéo 666 sinon on l'aurait fait
là et sa nourriture pourquoi la
nourriture de tamalous du temps ou parce
que sinon vanille mangerait la
nourriture de tam à dos mais thomas
l'eau a pris beaucoup de poids c'est à
dire qu'il est en régime en ce moment
mais le régime ne fonctionne pas très
bien car en le mettant au gym je me suis
rendu compte qu'il grossisse est
puisqu'il allait taper dans les
croquettes de vanille que je peux pas m
en hauteur elle déjà parce que tu as mal
aux pourrait y aller parce que manning
n'a pas la condition physique pour aller
au dessus d'une marche
voilà la cuisine si on allait plus loin
on verrait donc la chambre qui est
derrière cette vitre là il ya le couloir
ou au fond il ya la buanderie les
toilettes etc
la salle de bain je vous fais quand même
voir la salle de bain parce qu'elle a un
petit truc sympa c'est à dire que là
vous voyez les vielles qui est puis la
douce évidemment mais surtout cette
petite baignoire et ça à paris douche et
baignoire tellement rare que je me la
raconte dans la vidéo mais j'ai bien
conscience que si vous voyez cette vidéo
de province
ça vous paraît tout à fait normal comme
type d'appartement j'en ai bien
conscience
mais nous à paris dès qu'on a plus de 8
mètres carrés on se sent un petit peu
les rois de wall street et nous allons
terminer par l'endroit que vous
connaissez un petit peu pied le bureau
mais je vous le faire voir d'un peu plus
près la cour en était d'ailleurs avec
l'espèce de jungle devant un d'ailleurs
et à chaque fois qu'il ya des gens qui
passent il me regarde ce qu'il voit
toutes les lumières il voit un mec
parler devant la caméra je pense qu'il
se demande vraiment ce que je fais dans
la vie ici
ça c'est un flic est ce que je me suis
fait faire sur mesure il ya des années
17 de valises de vient de faire
mentaliser ça c'est une partie de tous
mes livres dont certains dont je vous
parle de temps en temps à faudrait que
vous fasse une vidéo sur la lecture
rapide on sait qu'à dit moins dans les
commentaires si la lecture rapide ça
vous intéresse c'est fait pour lire plus
vite comme son nom l'indiqué est enfin
mon spot de travail là où je passe ma
vie en fait sur ce bureau
je vais vous faire grâce des toilettes
qui n'ont pas grand chose d'intéressant
de la buanderie ce pareil la chambre bon
mais ma foi il ya un lit et le couloir
et alors et d'une originalité extrême je
préfère vous faire voir les quelques
pièces dans lesquelles je vis quand même
et dans lesquels tu as malodore en
permanence je viens de le voir juste là
dit bonjour mentale blogue ta malo voilà
là tu sais ce qu'ils font les gens et
cliquer sur j'aime pas ce qu'il voit ton
petit ventre évidemment si vous voulez
pas faire de peine à ta malo je vous
recommande de laisser un petit pouce en
l'air vous pouvez également commenter
cette vidéo c'est vous qui l'avez
demandé donc vous l'avez demandé vous
l'avez eue
pensez également à vous abonner avant de
quitter la vidéo parce que pendant
talent blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
ciao
il